chinook helicopters from the Dutch
military arrived at the German
Bundeswehr training facility at Ville
fleckman the first joined German Dutch
Corps is practicing for deployment to a
war zone NATO wants to be able to
respond to conflicts within a matter of
days this unit has been set up as part
of the Alliance's response to the
Ukraine conflict its headquarters are in
the German city of Muenster general Foca
hi Bauer and his Dutch deputy Leo Boylan
say they have until the end of the year
to develop a concept for what NATO calls
its spearhead and the landscape the
security policy has changed these days
we talk about conducting a hybrid war
about different operational scenarios
different elements that have to fit
together at the NATO summit in Wales the
decision was made to create these rapid
deployment forces they still don't exist
yet that's the challenge he is high do
not knees get dusty house water and it's
not just about reducing the response
time of combat units the generals say
the spearhead should be able to deal
with cyber attacks and should have
up-to-date surveillance capabilities
there are also plans for a small
permanent defensive basis in NATO's
eastern states when you forces from one
place to the other it's a static
complicated operation so in the in the
receiving end wherever that is there has
to be an element that we seize the
forces that the rifle theatres to get
them in the right place get them in the
in the right resources if there were a
military Emergency
the troops could be sent to such bases
in the Baltic States Poland Romania or
Bulgaria then bisca from the Brussels
think tank Egmont Institute says Russia
should not see that as a provocation it
is part of the package of deterrence and
deterrence is something that Europeans
have to rediscover the terrans of course
means nuclear deterrence but also
conventional deterrence what we forget
is that conventional deterrence also
supports European diplomacy our efforts
to to solve conflict
in our neighborhood diplomatically we'll
be strengthened if our neighbors know
that we have a credible deployable force
that can also operate outside Europe's
borders
Germany is taking on a key role in
developing venue forces providing the
majority of troops for the test phase
it's all part of NATO's strategy to
prepare for any possible escalation of
the conflict in Ukraine